more of the week 2 preview fill in the
blank style let's begin here peter the
49ers will be in trouble with the new
york jets if what
if
they don't get better play out of jimmy
garoppolo
he's going to have to carry a lot of
this team
with
how with with the injuries that they're
facing right now mike they go on the
road now they play twice in the
meadowlands in eight days they should
win both of these games
but now they enter into a very rough
patch of their schedule and again
it has nothing to do with the actual
foes on the schedule it is
you know what what coaches always say
hey listen we're not concerned about
anybody else we're only concerned about
how we play
well that's what kyle shanahan has to be
concerned with right now how we play
because it just wasn't good enough with
all the injuries they're dealing with
right now
this is when a franchise quarterback
steps up and he makes enough things
happen so that you win two winnable
games on the road
for me the 49ers are in trouble against
the jets if they end up having to sign
you and me to play cornerback because
it's getting to that point with all the
injuries they have in the secondary
richard sherman ir killer witherspoon
concussion protocol jason verrette
hamstring injury they brought up some
guys from the practice squad not that
the jets have a murderer's row of
receivers but if you don't have
defensive backs all of us plus the jets
are beat up at receiver two yeah
yeah on monday night football we learned
in the early game that the steelers what
and in the late game that the broncos
what
we learned that the steelers have more
weapons than the average nfl offense can
account for and that is obviously the
steeler defense because
how do you account for
tj watt cam hayward and bud dupree
and a rising secondary also in
pittsburgh so to me
that is what i learned about them and
what you learned about the denver
broncos
you know my feeling is just watching i
only watch the first half of that game
but in watching the first half of that
game the one thing i thought of is
please
give the ball to philip lindsay
philip lindsay is the best back
on that team
and i think he should be getting it 20
times a game every game
yeah and he never played in the second
half on monday night because he has turf
toes so we'll see when he's back about
the broncos i learned vic fangio is not
bill belichick he was trying to do that
super bowl 49 jedi mind trick on mike
vrable by not calling his timeouts late
it blew up on the broncos and the thing
about the steelers yes they still have a
great defense and that defense made the
difference against the giants that 26 to
16 margin
was a closer game than 10 points that
game could have gone either way until
the hit by dupree the ball pops up in
the air cam hayward picks it off that
was the moment it turned for the
steelers and the steelers host the
broncos uh in pittsburgh on sunday all
right next one patrick mahomes will what
against the chargers defense
explode
and it's not necessarily that the the
chargers defense is bad
but i think
at this time of the season
when the chiefs are almost all the way
around their offensive uh team you know
they're key guys they're they're a
healthy team right now to me when i look
at the kansas city chiefs
i think i i would hate to have to play
them in september in an average year i
want their guys a little bit beat up by
the time i play them but tough tough
scheduling for the chargers
yeah my big takeaway last week for the
chiefs and the texans was the chiefs
were playing a regular season game the
texans were playing a preseason game and
it's going to feel like that maybe even
more this week because the chiefs you
give andy reid extra time to get ready
you got a problem patrick mahomes i
think is going to have a huge game all
right last one josh allen bill's
quarterback his total game reminds you
of what
man
you know mike his total game reminds me
of
of a guy
who has got incredible potential
and he flashes it on about 80 percent of
his snaps
and that would worry me because he still
is
uh he still is prone to three or four
snaps a game that you say what in the
world is he doing
yeah it's like stumbling through a fun
house i mean you never know where that
trap door is going to be and it happened
a few times last week and they got away
with it but he's got to iron out those
kinks or it's going to hurt them at a
inopportune time like it did in the
playoffs against the texans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports